kendall Jenner takes the stand against
her alleged stalker
the reality star appeared in court
Thursday to testify as a witness about a
terrifying encounter at her home in West
Hollywood over the summer
Kendall explained to a judge and jury
that she found Siobhan McKenzie in her
driveway and claimed she came
face-to-face with him when he followed
her car into the garage oh it's just
kind of an emotional thing for me he
obtained court sketches showing Kendall
looking visibly shaken in court as she
recalled how she screamed at Mackenzie
six or seven times for him to leave
the judge granted the model a five-year
extension to her restraining order after
Thursday's hearing and Court docs
detained by ET in August
Kendall stated I fear for my life and
have suffered and continue to suffer
emotional distress I trained for things
as private as I can police arrested
Mackenzie at Kendall's home on August
14th and he pled not guilty to two
misdemeanors one count of stalking and
one count of trust passing the trial is
set to resume on Monday October 17th
with Kendall's housing supervisor taking
the stand